backlive is real and it's already in
Counter-Strike 2. not only will matches
be ended when a cheater is found but
offenders can potentially be banned the
moment they are reported it might be the
least sexy of all the new changes coming
to Counter-Strike 2 but it might just be
the most important and the most
expensive and after finally seeing an
action we've got quite a few questions
[Music]
so it's been about a week since we got
that big CS2 update and I speak for
everyone when I say it's been so much
fun watching everyone play Mirage
yeah but aside from all the gameplay
changes we saw was in my opinion the
biggest update coming to Counter-Strike
2. vac live and from what we've already
seen of it it's [__] crazy now weeks
ago I did a video talking about the
Rumblings of valve's new anti-cheat we
were getting from data Miners And in
that video I extensively spoke about how
big of an issue hackers are in CS go and
why an overhauled anti-cheat system
would change everything and while it
turns out all the data mining was legit
because valve has announced that vac has
been updated to banned players in real
time in their update they said quote vac
will now live ban and gracefully
terminate the match at the end of the
round unless it was last round and the
cheater lost the match will not affect
any participants skill group and players
that were not lobbied with the VAC band
Player will earn their XP for the match
now for a second I thought we'd have to
hold off on doing this video because we
wouldn't have had footage to show it off
but silly me this is Counter-Strike so
obviously people were cheating already
and obviously we saw back in action and
while the matches do end gracefully as
valve suggested the Banning part to say
it's abrupt would be an understatement
yes the [__] millisecond that buddy
reported his opponent for hitting a one
dig through the smoke he was blasted out
of the server and given a vacation now
though many commented on how funny it
was others pointed just how impressive
and potentially scary this new tech is
if this player was in fact cheating it
changes everything
no more frustration no more second
guessing every death you have no more
wasted time if they somehow weren't
cheating then it's concerning false
bands are obviously a thing in online
games and valve is no stranger to
handing those out the question is with
something this powerful will it lead to
a staggering amount of that occurrence
or is it truly sophisticated enough to
be infallible at this point valve has
yet to release any more information on
the details of that live but given its
importance I'm sure they'll dedicate
quite a bit of marketing towards it just
don't expect them to explain exactly how
it works for obvious reasons devs try to
stay pretty tight-lipped when it comes
to their anti-cheat software they don't
want to give out anything that might tip
off someone with nefarious intentions so
for the time being all we can really do
is speculate one option is that vac
detected the account as being a bit sus
already and they were just waiting for a
report to hand out the band but if this
software is as powerful as we think it
could be once the player was reported
vac did a live check found something and
then banned the player and as a valve
pen tester said in the replies this
seems to be the case there has been
quite a bit of discourse recently about
the things that valve are taking from
Valerian to be used in CS2 and while I'm
guilty of propagating this as well in
the case of this anti-cheat being
similar to Vanguard I don't think it
matters whatsoever if a game is fun and
satisfying the only thing that players
ask for is a competitive environment
where they can trust the results of
every gunfight and improving things like
tick rate and anti-cheat are the best
ways to do this and for valve's sake I
hope it works out because as history
shows this [__] is very very expensive
in an interview conducted by a16z games
with raid base the new studio built by
the co-founders valorant the OG
designers detailed just how costly these
quality of life improvements are so we
never saw Valor as a feature fight there
except that there were certain features
that were so important we called them
table things like anti-cheat again I
have quit every shooter because of
cheating we that was we wanted to invest
more into that than anyone else
how hard is that
the hardest how expensive is that
literally tens of millions of dollars if
anyone is making a shooter without
the full force of a big company
I wish you the best this just highlights
how big of a commitment things like back
live and the subtik servers are it's
likely that without these features
Counter-Strike 2 with its existing
improvements would still be a very
popular game but choosing not to puts
everything at risk for valve Believe It
or Not vac was pretty revolutionary for
its time and I'm sure it cost millions
of dollars to create and operate but
just like the 60 Tech servers it's
starting to show its age as The Valor
Founders also said in that interview
developing a game these days is not a
battle of Innovations almost everything
has been done before to some capacity
the true battle is the commitment you
have to offering your player base an
experience that is as smooth as possible
are you willing to put the time and
money in or are you just going to ride
on the coattails of your IP well with
the progress already made on vac live
and the subtext servers it seems that
valve is 100 committed to that Pursuit
and I hope to god it works out
unless someone's blatantly hacking then
obviously like I'll report them but if
someone's like super sus and people are
calling them out I usually will just be
like ah someone else will report them I
don't want to be the person that dog
piles on someone but at the same time
those people could also be smurfing and
in both cases I mean
see you later